could Kylie Jenner and Jordan Woods's
friendship be on the mend
well TBD but there is a glimmer of hope
you guys Jordans mama
Elizabeth woods has been showing the
makeup moguls on love on social media on
Monday Kylie posted this sweet pic of
her one-year-old daughter stormy along
with a clip of the tiny tot walking
around while on vacay with her famous
mama and dad rapper Travis Scott big
stick
Elizabeth dropped three heart emojis in
the comments now three heart emojis may
not seem like a big deal but let's not
forget that Jordan allegedly hooked up
with Khloe Kardashian's man
Tristan Thompson at a house party in
February ultimately ending his
relationship with Khloe
so three heart emojis I'd say that's a
bold move naturally Kylie and Jordan had
a massive falling-out and Jordan even
moved out of the reality stars home
following the whole messy ordeal Jordan
went on Jada Pinkett Smith's Facebook
watch show read table talk and claimed
she kissed Thompson but says nothing
else went down do you feel as though you
are the reason why Stan and Chloe are
not together I know I'm not the reason
that Tristan and Chloe are not together
now this situation may have made it
harder for her to want to be with him
right but I know I'm not the reason then
it went from bad to worse when Chloe
called Jordan a liar and blamed her for
the break-up on social media writing in
part quote at least be honest about your
story bTW you are the reason my family
broke up so that was some serious shade
she later took it back and then this
happened
Bam's noticed that the Kylie cosmetics
lip kits that were named after Jordan
were put on mega sale half off to be
exact and I should note that the shady
lipcott price was also slashed in half
but in a new interview with The New York
Times Kylie said the discount actually
happened before the scandal quote that
is just not my character I would never
do something like that
and when I saw it I was like thrown back
Jordan knows I didn't actually put it on
sale so will Jordan and Kylie ever be
able to salvage their besties status a
source tells ET that's entirely up to
Koko quote Kylie is still figuring out
where Jordan fits into her life and the
biggest reason is because Kylie wants to
respect her sister Chloe Chloe was
initially irate at Jordan and wanted
nothing to do with her
again however Chloe is a forgiving
person and she's just trying to see if
she can get over being hurt by someone
she considered a sister
so what's Jordan up to now well she's
living her best life London style the 21
year old has been spotted out and about
in the UK where she is promoting her
last collection rockin tons of different
looks here she is in the semi
see-through animal print number paired
with the leather jacket and she went
blonde for a night out on the town with
her mom sporting a peach number and a
metallic cropped jacket of course
Jordans London outings come on the heels
of Sunday's Keeping Up with the
Kardashians premiere in a trailer for
the new season it appears the drama will
be addressed it just sucks it has to be
so public I'm not just a TV show like
this is my life and Jordan she won't be
cut out of the show
here's to Jordan and Kylie
keeping up with the kardashians is a
full-time job and I can't wait to see
how the show handles this blow up of
course we'll be here to keep you up to
date on all things Jordan and Kylie so
be sure to keep it left on et until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]